ils sont une cinquantaine d'habitants à
évacuer à la balle heat emmené par ces
policiers qui les attendait sur ce
parking on a plusieurs buts
là on va partir d'autres vont arriver
sous les détonations ces familles ont
marché plusieurs kilomètres avec leurs
enfants car le pont routier qui sépare
la ville en deux et coupé
nous empruntons maintenant le passage
piéton le pont piéton que ses habitants
ont passé ce matin alors ils viennent du
nord de la ville là où se déroulent les
combats pour la première fois ou en tous
les cas c'est rare qu'ils le fassent
l'armée ukrainienne a reconnu qu'elle
perdait du terrain ici les forces de
moscou se sont emparés de plusieurs
villages autour de cette localité de
liman en fait l'armée russe essayent de
contourner les zones les plus denses
pour s'emparer de petites localités ils
le font avec un tapis de bombes ils font
très attention à ne pas faire de percée
fulgurante pour que leurs chars ne soit
pas pris sous le feu mais il avance